imaginez-vous ans
montagne à 2000 mètres d'altitude dans
les alpes vous êtes au pied d'une
falaise à proximité d'un lac cristal un
cluedo épure si elle est bleu le soleil
brille l'air est frais vous en prenez
plein les poumons
vous êtes dans un site protégé dans un
site éloigné des sources de pollution
éloigné des vallées polluer éloigné des
du trafic routier des incinérateurs des
industries polluantes etc etc et vous
êtes là dans le cadre d'un projet
scientifique avec vos amis chercheurs
avec vos amis plongeurs avec vos amis
chimiste et vous travaillez sur des
projets d'un avis d'eau en altitude et
vous rendez compte que même ici dans ces
sites protégés vous trouvé des
particules plastiques des micro
plastiques
voilà le triste constat qu'on a pu faire
ses étés à deux pas ici à deux pas d'ici
dans dans les alpes françaises
alors il s'agit pas de grosses
particules plastiques qui seraient issus
de la fragmentation déchets plastiques
qui aurait été rejetée par par les
skieurs par les randonneurs par les
alpinistes
il s'agit de quelque chose de beaucoup
plus fins les petites particules 50
microns à peu près les faits sur d'un
cheveu qui sont liés à l'utilisation
quotidienne du plastique à notre
utilisation quotidienne du plastique
dans les vallées qui parle dans
l'atmosphère et qui viennent se
redéposer dans tous les écosystèmes donc
le plastique est partout - le plastique
ans avec les océans était pollué on
savait que les cours d'eau et les
fleuves été pollués on sait maintenant
que même les montagnes des sites
protégés sont pollués il paraîtrait même
qui a dû placer dans l'assiette
puisqu'il ya des récentes études qui
tendent à prouver qu'ils auraient du
plastique dans le ciel et dans la bière
alors c'est un c'est un problème
environnemental on pollue les
écosystèmes et puis c'est également un
problème de économique parce que ça peut
ça peut impacter le le tourisme mais
aussi la pêche alors nous a mis quelques
chiffres pour illustrer un peu la
problématique le plastique a été a été
créée dans les années 50 démarrage de la
production plastic matériau miracle
miracle industriel un matériau léger et
tanches pas cher malléable bourré de
qualités d'ailleurs ça sa principale
qualité est aussi son principal défaut à
savoir sa longévité donc au départ
démarrage timide et puis ensuite la
machine s'emballe donc années 70 une
tonne par seconde de plastique étaient
fabriqués à l'échelle mondiale année 83
tonnes par seconde année 90 1
tonnes par seconde année 2007 tonnes par
seconde et aujourd'hui 2019 on a franchi
le cap de 10 tonnes par seconde
produite dans le monde chaque seconde
dans le monde 10 tonnes de plastique
sont fabriqués 10 tonnes de plastique
les experts sont formels si on continue
sur cette tendance à l'horizon 2050
durera plus de plastique de poissons
dans les océans
alors je suis pas en train de faire le
procès du classique le plastique
énormément davantage il ya des
nombreuses filières qui peuvent pas
vivre sans classique je pense notamment
à la médecine aéronautique à toute une
série de filières pour lesquelles le
plastique est extrêmement important par
contre sur cette masse énorme de
plastique et et qui est produite dans le
monde chaque seconde y en a 40 % qui
correspondent à l'emballage à du
plastique à usage unique donc dit
autrement 15 minutes d'utilisation pour
400 ans du réduit dans les écosystèmes
mais on a tous en tête le suremballage
l'emballage de fantaisie le tout jetable
vous savez ce paquet de biscuits
enveloppés dans du plastique ont louvre
derrière on a une boîte cartonnée
plastifiée on louvre on a une barquette
en plastique qui contient elle même des
sachets individuels de cas de biscuits
voilà c'est plastique c'est un peu comme
le cholestérol ya le bon cholestérol
mauvais cholestérol est typiquement le
plastique à usage unique c'est du
mauvais cholestérol
alors si on peut aussi regarder
maintenant à l'échelle mondiale
comment ça se passe il ya deux
phénomènes à l'échelle mondiale il ya
d'abord les pays riches et puis ensuite
il ya les pays pauvres alors pays riches
phénomène des pays riches c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup de consommation de plastique
principalement l'amérique du nord
l'europe la chine et puis le japon
considère qu' à peu près 10 fois plus de
production de plastiques danse et dans
ces pays là que dans les pays pauvres
et puis deuxième phénomène des pays
pauvres alors les pays preuve le
problème c'est pas tant qu'ils
consomment beaucoup de place hic c'est
qu'ils ont des taux de collecte qui sont
très faibles taux de collecte et
traitement qui sont très faibles
le taux de collecte dans un pays est
directement liée au niveau de pib plus
le pib est élevé plus le pays collecte
plus le pays des ébats - le pays
collecte ben c'est normal d'ailleurs
quand on ne sait pas comment on va
manger la journée où on sait pas comment
nourrir ses gosses la gestion du
plastique et pas forcément la priorité
de la journée donc deux phénomènes pays
riches paient pour vous pourrez dire
finalement le problème c'est les pays
pauvres puisque la fuite elle est chez
eux
alors oui oui sauf que
pays riches on exporte une partie nos
déchets plastiques vers les pays pauvres
donc en fait les pays riches consomment
beaucoup de plastique
il exporte une partie de la place vers
les pays pauvres les pays pauvres en
effet toute collecte et voilà la boucle
est bouclée la pollution n'a pas de
frontières alors comment on en est
arrivé là comment on arrivait finalement
dans une situation où on a dix tonnes
par seconde de plastique qui sont
produites dans le monde et où dans le
même temps on a un tiers de cette masse
énorme de déchets qui est mal gérée
quand je dis mal géré ses soit non
collectés soient envoyés dans des
décharges sauvages soit dans des
décharges non contrôlées
on en est arrivé là tout simplement
parce qu'on n'a jamais considéré la
problématique du plastique dans la
globalité de son cycle de vie
et oui le plastiki à un cycle de vie au
même titre qu'un être humain un cycle de
vie un être humain il est heavy humeur
et le plastique il est fabriqué il est
utilisé et ensuite il est jeté
alors c'est une chaîne finalement avec
différents maillons premier maillon le
fabricant de matière plastique vierge
donc depuis le pétrole jusqu'aux
plastique deuxième maillon le fabricant
d'objets en plastique troisième maillon
l'utilisateur et 4e maillon le déchet
alors bien souvent quand on raisonne au
niveau du plastique ont ce concert on se
concentre uniquement sur la dernière
fade sur dernier maillon de la chaîne
donc le déchet qui est une partie
importante du problème mais qui n'est
qu'une partie d'un enfant d'un ensemble
beaucoup plus vaste
si je reprends le premier maillon donc
le fabricant massique de matière
plastique vierge lui son métier c'est
quoi c'est transformé du pétrole en
matière plastique vierge pétrole c'est
ni plus ni moins qu du le plastique
c'est ni plus ni moins que du plastique
solidifier donc lui cet acteur là il
n'est pas du tout responsable de la
matière plastique une fois qu'elle était
produite il est pas responsable ni des
coûts de collecte ni des coûts de
traitement
donc la conséquence de tout ça c'est une
matière plastique vierge qui est
introduite sur le marché est beaucoup
trop peu cher par rapport à ce qu'elle
devrait être
elle devra intégrer ce qu'on appelle les
externalités donc tous les coûts de
dépollution qu'elle peut générer donc
problème numéro 1 trop de plastiques
introduit à l'échelle mondiale sur le
marché si je prends le deuxième maillon
de la chaîne donc le fabricant d'objets
en plastique donc lui son métier c'est
d'utiliser la matière classique vierge
qui a été fabriqué par le premier acteur
en des objets plastiques des brosses à
dents des pare chocs de voitures des
montres etc etc alors lui non plus ce
facteur-là et pas ou peu associés
coût de collecte et traitement de ces
déchets donc ça se traduit par des
modèles commerciaux qui vont privilégier
le plastique à usage unique
le plastique non recyclés plastiques non
recyclables hors jeu tempère un peu mes
propos il ya déjà de nombreux pays dont
la france fait partie qui ont mis en
place des mécanismes qui s'appelle la
responsabilité élargie du producteur qui
permettent via d'éco-conception
d'intéresser d'associer le l'industriel
à travailler différemment et à faire des
produits qui soient plus recyclable ou
moins mois pénalisé au niveau plastique
mais actuellement c'est pas du tout
suffisant et surtout c'est pas
généralisé à l'échelle du monde
énormément de pays qu'on peut a mis en
place cette ce type de procédé donc
deuxième problème au niveau cet acteur
trop de place était à usage unique trop
de plastiques non recyclables tour de la
cinor cycle je prends le troisième
maillon de la chaîne donc l'utilisateur
alors l'utilisateur c'est vous et moi
c'est ses citoyens c'est la collectivité
publique c'est l'entreprise
d'ailleurs c'est le maillon de la chaîne
qu'on aime bien culpabiliser parce qu'on
dit bah tiens ils sont pas vertueux ils
jettent leurs déchets dans la nature
bien évidemment qui a des comportements
qui sont qui sont non vertueux mais en
même temps qu aurait pas forcément
toujours les conditions qui permettent
aux citoyens de vivre différemment
et puis enfin dernier maillon de la
chaîne donc le déchet tout au moins
l'acteur qui va traiter les déchets hors
secteur lui supporte injustement le
fardeau financier lié au traitement des
déchets et oui il est au bout de la
chaîne il ya trois grandes voix
d'élimination des déchets au niveau
mondial il ya tout d'abord
l'enfouissement des charges ça c'est pas
forcément une solution vertueuse là vous
êtes tous étudiants mais globalement
quand on met du plastique en et charges
on ne fait que reporter le problème sur
les sur les générations futures donc pas
forcément très vertueux une deuxième
solution qu'on voit de plus en plus et
l'incinération
alors la sidération et pas forcément non
plus vertueuse puisqu'on va transformer
une forme de pollution l'occurrence le
plastique en une autre forme de
pollution en l'occurrence la pollution
de l'air quand on brûle du plastique on
émet des produits chimiques comme les
dioxines qui sont des produits qui sont
toxiques qui sont cancérigènes
ils sont qui cause des problèmes pour la
santé publique donc pas forcément
vertueux et étant entendu bien
évidemment que les incinérateurs font
l'objet de polémiques dans les pays
développés mais dans les pays non
développés souris sont pas contrôlées
soit il ya pas d'incinérateur mais le
feu directement aux ordures aux
poubelles donc deuxième solution pas
forcément vertueuse
et puis troisième solution de recyclage
on pourrait se dire c'est une solution
formidable alors oui oui sauf que sauf
que tous les plastiques sont pas
recyclables
les plastiques sont pas recyclables à
l'infini c'est pas une boucle fermée il
faut rajouter à un moment donné du
plastique vierge au sein de cette boucle
pour pouvoir pérenniser la chose et puis
c'est extrêmement compliqué de recycler
il ya des mélanges de plastique comme je
l'indiquais tout à l'heure qui rend
difficile certains composés plastique à
recycler et puis certains au plastique
contiennent des produits chimiques qu'on
a pas forcément envie de réintroduire
dans la chaîne des nouveaux produits et
puis enfin dernier point le recyclage
est actuellement pas rentables puisque
le différentiel de coût entre le mal la
matière plastique vierge gens issus du
pétrole et le plastique qui pourraient
être recyclés pas suffisamment grande
du coup le le coût de recyclage et pas n
est pas forcément n'est pas forcément
intéressant donc troisième problème
c'est pas la technologie qui va nous
sauver
donc en fait on est d'en face à quoi on
est face à une crise du plastique crise
du plastique en chine
le mot crise et de pictogrammes c'est à
la fois menaces et opportunités
donc j'ai plutôt me placer dans le dans
le camp des optimistes ya un philosophe
américain qui disait qu'un le pessimiste
se plaint du vent l'optimiste espère
qu'il va changer le réaliste ajuste les
voiles donc je pense qu'il est temps
d'ajuster les voiles et pour ça et quand
même des motifs d'espérance comme motif
d'espérance ya notamment les normes
prise de conscience mondiale de la
pollution plastique
depuis trois ans on peut pas ouvrir un
journal on peut pas lui même télévision
on peut pas lire un article sur internet
sans qu'on parle du plastique
les citoyens sont emparés de cette cause
est globalement le politique peut agir
quand le citoyen est prêt mais
manifestement il est prêt et les
consommateurs les industriels fabricants
général des produits qui sont le reflet
des consommateurs est manifestement les
consommateurs ont envie de changer donc
globalement il ya pas mal de solutions
qui commença qui commencent à voir le
jour
des solutions qui peuvent être que
globale il commença à faire à faire
consensus
première proposition signé un traité
mondial juridiquement contraignant on
peut pas travailler un pays
indépendamment de l'autre c'est pas
uniquement les usa uniquement l'europe
uniquement la chine ça peut être que
globale
et en terme de pollution planétaire on
pourrait s'inspirer d'un protocole qui a
été signé en 87 en l'occurrence le
protocole de montréal qui visait
également une pollution planétaire
les polluants qui avait un effet et qui
détruisait la couche d'ozone
si enfin l'analyse des politiques
publiques depuis une trentaine d'années
on sape en matière d'environnement on
s'aperçoit que c'est le protocole qui
est le mieux fonctionné
donc même problème pollution planétaire
mêmes effets on pourrait tout à fait
s'inspirer de ce protocole de montréal
pour traiter pour signer un traité
international qui permettrait de
s'affranchir travailler tous ensemble
pour la proposition deuxième proposition
comme je lui ai dit il faut agir sur la
globalité de la chaîne de vie du
plastique en coordonnant les actions et
en agissant sur chaque maillon de la
chaîne et en favorisant les interactions
entre les acteurs donc ça ça peut se
traduire sur des actions à la fois sur
l'offre et sur la demande donc les
entreprises et les citoyens est la
déclinaison opérationnelle c'est quoi
c'est la suppression du plastique à
usage unique
c'est favoriser la réutilisation en sens
on parle beaucoup aujourd'hui la
réapparition la consigne comme nos
grands parents avaient l'habitude
d'utiliser la consigne qui est
d'ailleurs l'objet de la nouvelle loi
sur l'économie circulaire porté par le
gouvernement donc plutôt que de htds
jeter mans pourrait réutiliser dévoila
des bouteilles en plastique ou des
bouteilles en verre ou des bouteilles en
faire c'est particulièrement pertinent
en cette période
et puis enfin dernier la dernière voie
favoriser le recyclage donc en associant
bien évidemment les industriels pour ne
pas mélanger les plastiques ou pour
éviter la mise en place de produits
chimiques dans les plastiques donc
deuxième proposition
et puis troisième proposition j'ai vu
tout à l'heure la fuite de plastique à
lui dans les pays pauvres donc aider les
pays pauvres à mieux connecter à mieux
traiter leurs déchets donc voilà trois
propositions de bon sens qui commence à
faire un peu consensus dans la
communauté et qui sont simplement des
actions qui visent à penser globalement
et agir localement
pour terminer je vous ai mis la photo de
la tour eiffel pourquoi la tour eiffel
tout simplement pour pour illustrer la
masse énorme de plastique qui est
générée dans le monde à chaque instant
je vous ai parlé une dizaine de minutes
durant ce court laps de temps a été
produit dans le monde l'équivalent en
plastique du poids de la tour eiffel dix
mille tonnes je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]